[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hi, and
welcome to episode 180
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark.
Hi, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I feel
like the Spiderman meme
where we're both
pointing at each other.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, we're doing
that for people who can't
see us, which is everybody.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, pretty much.
Awesome.
So what are we
talking about today?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, today
we've got a great interview
with Jen Person, who
actually just recently became
a cloud-focused
developer advocate
but used to be on the Firebase
Developer Advocate team.
And as such, she came in to
tell us a little bit more
about some of the cool
recent announcements
for Firebase after I/O,
a little bit more--
I mean, there's been a couple
of episodes about Firebase,
but it's such a wide topic.
You know?
There's so much there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We actually-- I went
back and looked.
We hadn't talked about
Firebase since about 18th
of October, 2017.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
a year and a half.
MARK MANDEL: So
you know, there's
been a bit of stuff coming up.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: People
have been working on it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
They've been up to some things.
So yeah, that's a really
cool conversation.
And then after that,
I get to ask you
a tough question, which is, how
do I save money on my Google
Cloud Platform resources?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Super important.
I know everybody-- well,
everybody wants state money.
MARK MANDEL: People like money.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It turns out.
MARK MANDEL: It's a thing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It's kind of important.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But
before we get to that,
we've got to talk about the cool
thing or things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So what do you got?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, the first thing
I'd like to start off with
is this really cool blog post
we had not too long ago talking
a little bit about uploading
images to cloud storage
using a signed URL.
So traditionally, you'd
have an image uploader.
You'd have a service
to handle that,
and then you'd send it off.
But it turns out that can
be really hard to scale.
So this little blog
post goes through some
of the details of
how you can generate
a signed URL specifically
for the user,
send it to cloud storage, which
handles a lot of storage--
more than a few, probably.
MARK MANDEL: Just a
couple little bits, yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: A few million,
billion, something like that.
And then generates
that signed URL,
and you give it to your app.
It allows them to upload that
directly to cloud storage,
so there's no middle
person needed.
So you can just upload the file,
and then you're good to go.
So it's actually a
really, really cool way
to remove an unnecessary
component of file uploading.
Now you don't need to
handle that with your stuff.
You handle it directly
with cloud storage.
MARK MANDEL: And it's secure.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Super easy, secure.
That signed URL obviously
expires relatively--
you can tell it when to expire.
It makes the process
a lot easier.
And really, I think
it's about, again,
focusing on the actual
application as opposed
to the infrastructure behind it.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Fantastic.
Well, we've got a blog post
and a matching solution
for a build your own
event sourced system
using Cloud Spanner.
I like this a lot.
This is-- basically, the
example they use here
is something like an
e-commerce system where,
say, a customer adds
something to a cart,
and then they click
Checkout, and then they
have payment processing.
And you want to
track all the events
all the way through that flow.
But then you want to do
stuff based on that event.
So the whole solution
takes you through how
you can use Spanner to do that,
how you can build a polling
system to update other systems
about when that happens so
that you could take that
data and, say, push it
into BigQuery, or
put into Pub/Sub,
or do all sorts of other
interesting things.
You could keep like
historical records
and all that kind of stuff.
So we'll have a link
in the show notes.
So you can check that out
if that's the sort of thing
that you might be interested in.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I think it's cool.
When you design
a site like that,
you might be focused very
much on how people use it.
But then you actually
have to analyze
what's going on, where any
triggers are happening,
and then eventually, how
do we take that information
and do something with it.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Super cool.
Well, another cool thing
that I recently discovered--
I actually have no idea
when this happened.
It may have been today.
It may have been a month ago.
It may have been
a long time ago.
But it turns out
that Google Cloud--
I think it's called
Cloud Console, which
is a Google Cloud--
MARK MANDEL: The mobile app?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, the mobile app
on Android and iPhone--
or iOS, I should say.
That actually has the ability to
get Cloud Shell in it as well.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, neat.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So we were
talking not too long ago
about how cool Cloud
Shell is, and it gives you
this safe workspace
you can play around in.
And it gives you the G
Cloud command line tool
so you can integrate with
all the other Google Cloud
processes.
But now you can have
that from your phone.
So there's been
a couple of cases
where I've been away on holiday
or something of that nature.
And then someone's like,
oh, hey, the server is down,
and this and this.
First of all, serverless.
Second of all, you still have to
go in and do something, right?
And being able to have the
power of the-- honestly,
just the G Cloud command
line from your phone--
that's amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
I knew you could SSH into a
GCE instance on your phone.
I did not know that you
could use Cloud Shell.
That's pretty awesome.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
Now you don't even--
you could probably
set up a bastion somewhere, and
then just put G Cloud on it,
and use that as a proxy.
But now you don't
even need that.
MARK MANDEL: You
don't need to do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You just have
it straight from your phone.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That is amazing.
Fantastic.
Last, this is an
interesting article.
It's called "Google Cloud
Networking In Depth--
Cloud Load Balancing
Deconstructed."
So I think this actually has two
really interesting things to it
that you probably
should be interested in.
One, if you're ever like,
how does Google Cloud
do networking?
How do the things work
behind the scenes?
This is a really
good article too.
But if you were also looking
at it from perspective
of which load balancing
solution should I
be using for the things
that I want to do,
this also has a really
nice comprehensive summary
there too.
So it goes through
network load balancing.
It goes through global load
balancing, some of the things
that we do on the
edge for security,
how we optimize for latency
with CENs and things like that,
different network
tiers, stuff like that.
It's a really nice
overview of the things
we do in the networking space.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I think we
see a lot of people who are--
maybe they come to
the cloud, and they
don't realize how
different it is
from your traditional
networking setups,
especially people who have
been working at a data
center for a long time.
And so the more content
we see like this--
I think there's
actually a series
of deep dives on
the blog that go
into different components,
this one about load balancing
specifically.
But there's so much out there
that helps people understand--
look, the cloud really is
different-- for the better,
I'd like to say.
But at the very least, we
need more resources for people
to get that access
and understand, hey,
this is how it works.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Super cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we
go chat with Jen?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Sounds good.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: OK, everyone.
We're super excited to have
Jen Person with us here today,
a Cloud Developer Advocate.
Jen, tell us a little bit
about yourself and what you do.
JEN PERSON: Well, thank you.
As you said, I am a
Cloud Developer Advocate,
as of starting this week.
Prior to that, I was a
Firebase developer advocate.
And I also made some courses
around Firebase in partnership
with Udacity.
So I do a little of
traveling, giving talks.
I do a lot of recording
videos, do some blogs,
answer a bunch of people's
questions on Stack Overflow,
and also answer some
questions on Twitter.
So if you're in the
Firebase community,
I've probably answered your
question once or twice.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, very excited to have you
on the Cloud Developer Advocate
team.
And since we have you now
on the Cloud Developer team,
I think now we should just
talk to you about our Firebase.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: What we
need is a Firebase expert.
Now we have that.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
So yeah, Jen, thank
you for coming
to talk to us about Firebase.
We have done-- I went and
had a look at 1, 2, 3, 4--
[INAUDIBLE]?
4 and 1/2 because Firestore
sort of crosses boundaries.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
First question--
tell us about Firestore.
We'll get to that in a sec.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
get to that in a sec.
So yes, but if people haven't
caught any of the 4 and 1/2
episodes previously,
can you give us
a little overview of Firebase?
What does it do?
What's the cool stuff about it?
JEN PERSON: Yeah so
Firebase is a suite
of products to help
you build your app
and grow your user base.
I sort of think of it as
the application, the client
side of Google Cloud.
So basically, any
solution you could
need in your app, like be
it authentication or data
storage or dynamic links,
all sorts of things,
analytics all available, one
stop shop within Firebase.
And it is cross-platform
for iOS, Android, web.
We also have C++, Unity
SDKs, basically covering all
the client SDKs as well as
a big server side offering.
So we're basically trying to
solve all of your development
problems.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Just the
whole front, back, the middle,
everything.
MARK MANDEL: I
don't even know why
we have Google Cloud anymore.
No idea.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, just
replace the whole thing.
Well, actually, that's a
really interesting point.
Because if Firebase offers a
lot of these more client-facing
things, but it does offer
some database side of things,
some more of the server end--
but you can also use
Firebase, the client side,
to integrate with any of the
GCP back end stuff, right?
JEN PERSON: Right, yes.
So a lot of times
we get questions
like, what is the difference
between Firebase and Google
Cloud?
And it's not so much that
there's a difference.
There's sort of-- if
it's a Venn diagram,
Firebase is somewhat
overlapping for the most
part with Google Cloud.
So they share a lot
of the same services,
but the Firebase side
really is developed
to be for client side
developers for the most part
to make your job easier, where
Google Cloud is, generally
speaking, more enterprise.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And it does
seem like Firebase is more--
I've heard it referred to
as back end as a service,
or maybe serverless?
Would that be accurate?
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
So we have a whole
bunch of features
that are back end as a service.
We also have a lot of
growth features as well.
MARK MANDEL: What do you
mean by growth features?
JEN PERSON: Oh.
Well, I'm glad you asked.
So after your app
is built, you need
a way to connect with your
users and expand that user base.
So that could be
through notifications
or through A/B testing.
You can use Remote
Config, which allows
you to change some details about
how your app works or appears.
So you can try different
configurations,
and see which ones
your users like better,
and really just
optimize your app.
And a lot of times,
we'll have a good idea,
but how do you really
hone it and make it
exactly what your users want?
Our growth features
help you do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So it's this suite
of tools that help you
design all these things.
And those old podcast episodes
that talk about Firebase
go into a lot of details.
What's new with Firebase?
What have we seen, especially
with I/O just recently
last month?
What's new and cool with it?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I went back and looked.
Our last episode
was back in 2017,
so I assume some new
stuff has come out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Probably at least a thing.
JEN PERSON: Yeah,
a couple things.
So one of the things that's
really interesting about how
Firebase has been developing
is that when we first started,
we just were growing
and growing and adding
all these different products.
And now what I
see Firebase doing
is really maturing, and adding
to those different products
that we already have,
and making them really
suit the developers
based on the feedback
that we're getting from you.
So in terms of
existing products,
things we've added to
them, for Cloud Firestore,
which is our second
database offering,
it's also NoSQL like
the Realtime Database.
And it is built of
collections of documents.
It's no longer in beta.
MARK MANDEL: Yay!
JEN PERSON: So I know that was
a deterrent for some developers.
You're worried
about, do I really
want to push this to production
if it's something in beta?
Well, it's not anymore, so
it's really a mature product.
Really excited about
how it's been working.
I absolutely love how it's
solved problems that I
faced in the past with NoSQL.
And very recently, we just
added collection group queries.
So prior to that, you could
not make a specific query
that spanned across
different subcollections
and different documents.
So subcollections were seen
as just completely separate
entities from one another.
But now you can query,
and it'll pull the key
from every subcollection.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
So is this kind of like a
newer version of the Realtime
Database?
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
I would say that that's
the simplest explanation.
But we are still
definitely supporting
the Realtime Database.
The real time nature of it
has just been really helpful
for a lot of scenarios.
And so it's still
going to be there,
and it still may be suited
best for certain situations.
For instance, if you are
doing a whole lot of writes
very quickly, the
Realtime Database
might be a better solution for
you, so things like in games.
But I see Cloud Firestore
as the next step
because it adds stronger
querying, better querying
power, a structure that
it makes more sense
to mirror your
application, basically
all the answers to the
questions that people
had about Realtime Database.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And it has
kind of a broad use case,
like you said, for a lot
of people since we were--
actually, at the beginning,
just talking about, well, you
can actually get
Firestore through GCP
rather than through-- you can
do it through both Firebase
or through GCP, again,
depending on your use case.
JEN PERSON: Yeah, exactly.
And that actually
means that if you're
starting with a very
small team, and you're
building an
application, and then
it becomes extremely popular,
switching over to Google Cloud
is a breeze.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
I don't think
we've ever actually
talked about that on any
of the previous episodes.
Because there's a really
nice graduation path,
I think, as you go
to Firebase, and then
if you wanted to add
extra features into GCP.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
JEN PERSON: Yeah, sure.
So whenever you create
a Firebase project,
it's also a Google
Cloud project which
enables you to implement any
of the Google Cloud APIs right
from the Google Cloud console.
And there is also,
as you pointed out,
some overlapping features
like Cloud Firestore,
like Cloud Storage, which
is available specifically
for Firebase, but
it's the same Cloud
Storage underneath that
we use in Google Cloud.
And recently, we added
Identity Platform.
So now we have auth
features in cloud
that add on to the
Firebase Auth features
and really are suited for
those enterprise situations.
And switching over
is really simple
because you already
have your project.
You don't have to
worry about trying
to link projects together.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it
might be a good example
that someone started
with Firebase,
and then they added
a little bit more,
and then they wanted to build
in some more GCP projects--
or GCP products.
But it might also
go the other way
where you're using
GCP products, and you
want to add a mobile app
or something like that.
And it would make
just as much sense
to create that Firebase project
and go off of that, right?
JEN PERSON: Yeah, absolutely.
And if you have an existing
Google Cloud project,
you can import it into Firebase.
So yeah, you can
definitely go either way.
And there are situations
where, as you pointed out,
if you want to build a client
app, that would make sense.
And a lot of times, we will
be using cloud APIs even when
you're using Firebase.
So if you wanted to do some
sort of translation server
side or something
like that, we would
use Google Cloud for that.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
You mentioned one thing
in passing that is--
I don't know.
It's always been my
favorite feature of Firebase
is Firebase Auth.
And having built--
I don't know--
websites for 20 years,
not having to build an
authentication scheme
seems really cool.
But it looks like you've
had some improvements
in the last couple
of years on that too.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
In the last couple of years,
we've added several new ways
to authenticate.
We added phone auth.
We added email link auth.
So rather than having
an email and password,
you can send an email link.
And you can click
on it in your email.
We've added different
email actions.
So in the console,
you can decide
what is the message that you
want your clients to get when
they get, say, an
email to verify,
or you can change that
from the client as well.
And our latest identity
providers that we've added
are Microsoft and Yahoo Auth.
And now we're going to be using
a generic OAuth 2 provider
sign-in.
So going forward, it's
going to be even easier
to add different providers.
You may have noticed in the
past each provider maybe
has a little bit different
way that it works.
You need to log in,
say, with Facebook,
and then they have
their own portal,
and then you have to
take that information
and use it to log
in to Firebase.
But now with that OAuth 2
provider sign-in being generic,
it basically just
pops up a web window,
and they all work the same.
And that's going to make
it a lot easier for us
too to add more providers.
So hopefully we'll have
more providers going forward
quicker.
MARK MANDEL: No more having
to implement and reset
your password functionality.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Don't
build your own auth.
Just don't.
MARK MANDEL: Don't
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's a
very small set of use cases
where you need to.
But otherwise, man,
you just don't.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
One time I watched this how
it's made show on YouTube
about making soy sauce.
And soy sauce is basically
water and salt and soy beans.
Right?
So you could theoretically
make your own soy sauce.
But wouldn't you rather
just make dinner?
That's kind of how
I think about it.
Yes, you can spend all
of your development time
making this very complex
thing like handling auth,
or you can make what
you went out to make,
the application that you
wanted to make, and leave that
to us because we have all
this experience with it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I feel that way
about any cooking whatsoever.
I could make this
bowl of cereal,
but wouldn't I rather have
someone make the bowl of cereal
and just give it to me?
MARK MANDEL: And just
deliver it to my house.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
JEN PERSON: That's a
great idea for an app--
cereal delivery.
MARK MANDEL: I would
pay money for that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I, sadly,
would pay money for that.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
One thing I actually
have been also dying
to talk about on the
podcast, but we haven't had--
just haven't had a
chance, unfortunately--
ML Kit is super interesting.
Tell us more about that.
I think that's fascinating.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
So what ML Kit does is it
provides you a simplified way
to use machine learning on your
client's app or on the server.
And we have all sorts
of different ML features
that we're slowly adding to it.
And so the benefit of using
ML Kit is that we have--
with on-device ML
features, you are
able to use them even if you
don't have internet access.
So it leads to a much
quicker experience.
We're able to do things
like if you have a video,
and you're just
filming in the moment,
you could do real time
text recognition or face
detection, because it's
right there on the device.
So it's super fast.
And if you need something
a little more powerful,
you could still
use the cloud side,
and it's done simply
through our SDK.
So right now for ML Kit,
wow, it's growing so fast.
I swear there's a new
feature every week.
I actually had to look it up
to make sure I got them all.
In terms of natural
language, we have
identifying language of text.
We have Translate, and we
also added Smart Reply.
We have a lot of
Cloud Vision features,
including recognizing text,
detecting faces, including
landmarks on the
face-- so not just
detecting the square of a
face, but where's the nose,
where are the eyes?
It helps you make all
those fun filters.
Scanning barcodes,
which is super popular,
labeling images,
detecting and tracking
objects, which we
recently added,
and recognizing
popular landmarks.
And we also added
AutoML Vision Edge.
So if you have a
custom AutoML model,
you can access it
right on your device.
So you can see
that's another way
that there's an overlap between
Google Cloud and Firebase.
And if you really need
a customized model,
you can use TensorFlow Lite.
You can run your TensorFlow
Lite model through ML Kit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's
pretty much ML Kit is the way
to use any ML technology
with your mobile slash web
slash whatever app, right?
JEN PERSON: With your iOS
and Android app, yeah.
Our goal, I think, is just to
cover any and all scenarios.
And we're really excited
to see how people
are going to be using it.
And we also have a Google Group.
So if you want to join that
and follow along and see
how other people
are using ML Kit,
we'd love to see how
you're using it as well.
MARK MANDEL: I'm just kind
of excited about having
Smart Reply as a service.
I'm trying to think of
wonderfully horrible things
I can do with that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I think
we're going to get to the point
where you don't need to--
MARK MANDEL: Even be there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You don't
need to respond to anything,
and you'll still be responding.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right? your
ML will kind of figure you out
as a person, which
is a scary thought.
But then after that, you're
like, the infinite convenience
I have--
I can have my phone order my
cereal for me in the morning
and have to do nothing,
assuming we build the cereal
service first.
MARK MANDEL: I don't need to
do podcast hosting anymore.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And Auto ML-- hmm.
Wait, wait.
No.
We shouldn't explore
this concept.
I need this job.
MARK MANDEL: And you also--
before the podcast, we were
talking about Cloud Functions
as well.
We did do a previous episode.
I think that was the last one.
Yeah, it was in 2017.
But I'm sure Cloud
Functions have also
come a long way since then.
JEN PERSON: Yeah, yeah.
Cloud Functions for Firebase
are no longer in beta.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yay!
JEN PERSON: So yeah, these were
the two big pushes that we had,
Cloud Firestore and
Cloud Functions.
And getting those out of beta
into BGA has been really great.
So we are continuing to add
different types of triggers.
I'm trying to guess
which ones have
been added since the previous--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Guessing
at production launches
seems like a good idea.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just guess.
It'll be fine.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
So let's see.
We have now a
Crashlytics trigger.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's cool.
JEN PERSON: So if you
have some sort of crash,
you can trigger a
function, and then you
can use that function to, say,
send a notification to Slack
or something like that.
And my favorite-- we now have
scheduled functions, so big
request there.
You can now schedule
your functions
to run at a specific
time and repeat.
And we have a new emulator that
can run your functions right
on your device without
touching your live code.
And it also emulates all
sorts of different things
in your app.
If you're using
Cloud Firestore, you
can basically have a whole
ecosystem working right
from your device and not
worry about accessing
external live code.
And you can test it out.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
Is that using the Firebase
command line utility
or something to set that up?
JEN PERSON: Yeah, the
command line utility.
MARK MANDEL: Well, that
was way easier than--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I thought
there was going to be more.
MARK MANDEL: I thought
It's like, no. no.
You just go Firebase.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
When you have the
CLI, you just have it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So a common
use case for some people
might be setting up
their app, hooking
into a Firestore
for the database.
And then when some
event happens,
or when they upload a
certain amount of data
to Firestore, that then
triggers a function,
does a little bit
of processing on it,
and then maybe puts it
back in, or like you said,
sends a notification.
The possibilities are
probably endless there.
JEN PERSON: Oh, yes, definitely.
And it's great because
it also connects
with all sorts of
third-party services as well.
So it's not just exclusively
within the Google Cloud
environment.
You're able to incorporate
whatever third-party services
you need.
And for now, until we
add different types
of authentication,
it's also where
you can handle customer auth.
I know in our Functions
Samples Github repo,
we have an example of
logging in with Instagram.
And what else?
We used to have a
GitHub one, but now you
can log in with GitHub.
Yeah.
I had to take a look.
So yeah, we actually have a repo
full of Cloud Function samples
if you want some ideas about
how you could use them.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
We can put a link to
that in the show notes.
I'd love to know what's been
the most interesting or strange
thing you've seen somebody
build with Firebase.
JEN PERSON: That's
a great question.
Oh, OK.
So when I was at a hackathon--
so you're looking at having
a really limited
amount of time--
right now, in terms of deploying
Cloud Functions to Firebase,
you do that from the
command line interface.
But what they did is
basically make a website
where you can just type your
JavaScript code right into it,
and it deploys it
automatically for you.
And the way that it
worked was actually
just taking the actual
chunks of your code,
and turning them into
strings, and putting them
into the database.
And that would
trigger your function
that then reassembled
it and made that
into a Cloud Function.
I just thought it was a really
fascinating implementation.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
no way that could be abused.
Not a single-- not a single way.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, it's
super secure, super.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
Just give the ability for
anyone to put any code anywhere.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
JEN PERSON: That's why it's
a hackathon project, not
a real one.
But--
MARK MANDEL: You don't have
that project handy, do you?
I mean, never mind.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
So I thought that
was pretty cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That is very cool.
So you also-- we're
coming off of the I/O
and the next conference
season for Google.
You gave a talk at I/O, right?
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
So I gave a talk
with [? Cat Fang ?]
and Mike McDonnell and
Frank van Puffelen.
We did our "0 to App"
live coding talk.
This is something that we've
done at several events,
but this time we used a
brand new application.
So what basically
happens is one of us
is talking while the
other three of us
are coding on three
different platforms.
And it is wild.
It is amazing that
anything ever works.
And we really are coding
it and deploying it live.
MARK MANDEL: Have you
practiced it before,
or are you doing it all fresh?
Can you tell us?
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
With this particular app,
because we had just built it--
oh, gosh.
Is it bad to say we
probably practiced it, like,
two full times?
You know, like--
MARK MANDEL: That's more
times than I probably
would have done it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
that's pretty reasonable.
JEN PERSON: Each
of us on our own
tried to make sure that
our component was working.
But to bring it all
together probably
only happened a couple of times.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
One live demo is
dangerous enough,
but three live coding
sessions happening onstage
seems reasonable, right?
JEN PERSON: Oh, yeah.
I guess what I tell myself is if
I make a mistake, at least 2/3
of the people are probably
looking somewhere else.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's a good point.
MARK MANDEL: So all
three people's screen
are up on the stage
at the same time
so everyone can see everything.
JEN PERSON: Exactly.
It sort of looks like
the "Brady Bunch."
It's got different
screens all going at once.
MARK MANDEL: That's fantastic.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Did it work?
JEN PERSON: For the most part.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
that's pretty good.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty good.
JEN PERSON: I will say
that when I started my code
and I implemented auth,
when I went to log in,
it just gave me error code 2.
And I was like, great.
Great.
This is great.
MARK MANDEL: I hear
there's documentation
that might explain.
JEN PERSON: So fortunately,
it was my turn to talk.
And Puff came over, and he
was able to look at my code
while I was--
I had slides up so
you couldn't see it.
And what happened was we
were hardwired for internet
because that's
supposed to be faster.
But the internet they connected
me to, the ethernet cord,
didn't actually work.
So we just had to
connect to the Wi-Fi.
But yeah, that was
the only slip up.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's great.
Hashtag conference problems.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
So if people want to
learn more about Firebase,
what's your favorite
resource where
people can be able to do that?
JEN PERSON: Well, let's see.
I really do absolutely
love our guides,
which you can find on our
website, firebase.google.com.
But what I've found most
useful is our quick starts
which are also linked there.
But sometimes when
I'm just reading
a description of
something, I'm like, OK,
what does this
actually look like?
So if you go over
to the quick starts,
you can see how all
of those features
work separately and together,
and you can see it in the app
that it actually works.
And that helps it
make a lot more sense.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I hear that you
run a program called Firecasts.
What is a Firecast?
JEN PERSON: So a Firecast
is sort of like a--
generally brief-- we like
to have them less than 10
minutes--
video where we do some
screencasting, and we do some
maybe headshots with maybe
some nice diagrams where we
explain something in Firebase.
And that could be
a specific feature,
getting started with it.
That could be a problem and
showing you how Firebase
can help you solve it--
just a little bit of
information, not quite as big
as a tutorial altogether, but
just a little bit to get you
started.
MARK MANDEL: Also sounds like a
good resource for learning more
about Firebase.
JEN PERSON: Yes, definitely.
MARK MANDEL: Not that
the previous question
was leading in any way.
JEN PERSON: Oh, I missed that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We
almost thought ahead.
MARK MANDEL: Almost.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very close.
So how do you determine
what topics you
want to have on the Firecast?
It sounds like you have a
pretty diverse set of things
that you talk about.
JEN PERSON: Oh, yeah, yeah.
If you check it out, we
have a different Firecast
for almost every single product
on all of our platforms.
Personally, when it comes
to making new Firecasts,
I take a look at the kind of
questions that I'm getting.
So that's why those
are so important.
I was running a show called
AskFirebase up until recently.
And so people will use
the hashtag AskFirebase
on social media.
And I basically take
all of those questions,
and look at them,
and determine which
ones work best on the show.
But I also aggregate them.
I look at what are the common
themes that I'm seeing here.
Is there a problem that a
video could easily solve?
So I do it based on the kind
of questions people ask.
So keep those questions coming.
Even though I can't
answer every one directly,
it does help determine where--
the direction that
our product goes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Have there
been any recent insights
that you've gotten from
the AskFirebase that
have kind of been surprising?
JEN PERSON: Ooh.
That's a good question.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank you.
JEN PERSON: It's like you
know what you're doing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's weird.
It's like I'm a
host or something.
JEN PERSON: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Just kidding.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
JEN PERSON: Well, I
guess I'll say broadly,
I learned a lot about how
our products work just
from AskFirebase.
So there are specific
products within Firebase
that I focus most of my time on.
And a lot of times when I have
a guest coming on AskFirebase,
they work on a product that
I'm not so familiar with.
So it gives me a chance to
get those questions answered
and learn some
stuff along the way.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
think that's the beautiful part
about being in
developer relations,
is that when you're working
with these products internally,
you think about x, y, and z.
But then you hear from
people who are using them.
You're like, I never
thought of using it
like [? Jay. ?] You're
like, That's crazy to me.
But let's talk about it.
Let's figure it out, and let's
glean insights from that.
JEN PERSON: Yeah, exactly.
I always have in my mind how
I think I would use something,
but seeing how our developers
use it is very different.
MARK MANDEL: So now
I want to know-- now
that you've joined
the Cloud team,
are we going to expect similar
types of media content coming
from you on the cloud side?
Can you talk about that
yet, or is it secret?
JEN PERSON: Ooh, secret.
No.
Yeah, I'm definitely
going to be continuing
to make video
content because it's
my absolute favorite thing.
So I think there's going to
be a whole lot more of that
because I'm going to have
more time to dedicate to it.
So while I have
changed teams, you'll
definitely still see
my face around a lot.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Are we going
to look for a hashtag AskCloud?
It could be a good idea.
Write that one down.
I'll take credit for it.
JEN PERSON: Don't tempt me.
Yeah.
You know what?
I can just put out
the hashtag, and I'll
set up a spreadsheet so I can
start getting those questions.
And we'll just see if people
asking enough questions for us
to start a show.
MARK MANDEL: Did you
hear that, listeners?
The onus is on you.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It's all up to them who
are listening right now.
You can make this a reality.
We just need you to ask a
lot of relevant questions.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, we are coming up
on time a little bit.
But before we finish up, is
there anything that we missed,
or something you want
to make sure you plug,
or just things that
people should know about
before we finish up today?
JEN PERSON: So
anyone who listens
to this podcast has
probably already figured out
that Google Cloud is huge
and encompasses all sorts
of different products.
And even as someone
who works here,
I can find it confusing
sometimes trying
to get to the right resource.
So by all means, if you
have the possibility
to reach out to somebody
who works on Google Cloud
or works on
Firebase, they may be
able to point you in
the right direction.
They might know
where that resource
is that you're looking for.
So we really do have some
great documentation out there,
but sometimes finding
the exact solution
you're looking for is a little
harder, because maybe you'll
word it a little differently
when you're searching for it.
So yeah, going back to asking
questions, it's very important.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think there are so
many different products.
And even people come up to us
occasionally, and they're like,
oh, you're working in cloud,
so you know about this when
it's like, we don't.
A lot of times, there's
so much stuff here.
MARK MANDEL: So it just
sounds like ask Jen.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hashtag AskJen.
I will also take credit for
that if you choose to use it.
Sorry.
I'm just trying to put
my hooks in everything.
JEN PERSON: No, you got--
that is totally your idea.
So should I send the
questions your way then?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, that would be--
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
yes you should.
You should send it to Mark, yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, Mark can
answer those questions for you.
MARK MANDEL: No, the other Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
We're pointing.
I know it doesn't
work as well, but--
MARK MANDEL: It's like
a Spider Man comic
where we both point
at each other.
All right, wonderful.
Well, Jen, thank you so much
for coming here on the podcast
and telling us all
about Firebase today.
JEN PERSON: Thank
you, Mark and Mark.
MARK MANDEL: You're welcome.
Thanks, Jen.
JEN PERSON: Thanks.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
Thanks so much to
Jen for coming in.
It was super, super
awesome to hear about all
the cool Firebase things.
And now that she's
on the Cloud team,
we'll hear about many
awesome Cloud things as well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Sounds great.
I'm looking forward
to all the new content
she's going to produce.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's
going to be super cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So let's get to our
question of the week
to ask the tough questions.
What I want to know
is, how do I save money
on my Google Cloud
Platform resources,
just across all of them?
Can you solve all
those problems?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Just
every, every resource?
Well, the first thing you do
is just shut them all down.
MARK MANDEL: That is a good
way of saving money, yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You
will not spend anything
if you don't use anything.
Right?
The nice advantage of the cloud.
Turns out that does not
work for most people.
So a more realistic
approach is to actually try
to figure out what
you have that's
up and running that you're
paying for that you're not
really using.
And so there was this
super cool talk at Next
that's on YouTube-- and we'll
have a link in the description
below--
that talks a little
bit about how
to automate cost optimization
toolings basically
by scanning your
resources for things
you're not using that
you are paying for
and then shutting them down.
You can write that using Cloud
Functions pretty quickly,
and then it just goes into it.
So in the talk, they talk
a little bit about-- what's
the example they give?
Looking at-- so
external IP addresses--
I don't know if you knew this,
but you don't pay for them when
they're attached to a resource.
MARK MANDEL: But you do pay
for them if they're not.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There it is.
And so if you have an
external IP address that's
been sitting around for 30 days,
that's a pretty good chance
you may not need it.
Of course, that will
[? be ?] up to your business
logic if you actually
want it or not.
But if you're not saving
those for anything,
you can actually write
this cool function
that would go scan
all your IP addresses,
see which ones haven't
been used in a while,
and then shut them off, put that
on a Cloud Scheduler job maybe.
And then you've got
this great system
to automatically scan
for it and delete it,
saving you a little
bit of money.
So you can do that with
external IP addresses.
The talk also shows doing that
with persistent disks that
haven't been used, any
resources, Compute Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Load
balancers that might be
sitting around doing nothing.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: There's
so many different resources,
especially for
large organizations.
You can get lost in just
the sheer number of projects
you have.
So check the talk out.
It's super cool.
It gives them practical
examples and actual code
that you can run.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But then it should
enable people to
take a look at it
and say, where else might
I be wasting resources?
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
You can even just send reports.
You could do email reports.
That's just neat.
Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I mean, yeah.
Once your--
MARK MANDEL: The
world is your oyster.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Exactly.
If you want to email
somebody, set up a dashboard,
automatically delete
them, it doesn't matter.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Fantastic.
So Mark, what are you up to?
What cool things are you doing?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
next week, I am gone.
I am disappearing into
the ether for a week.
And then after that,
I will be in New York.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And then coming up,
I'll be going down to LA.
So a little bit of traveling.
Generally, I like
to stay where I am,
but moving around a little bit.
What about yourself?
MARK MANDEL: I will be at
Tokyo Next, presenting.
I'll be doing some stuff at the
E Games and Apps Inside event
right with Tokyo Next.
So unsurprisingly, I will
be talking about [INAUDIBLE]
and being around to talk
about games and stuff.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Mark
talking about [INAUDIBLE]??
MARK MANDEL: Who knew?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Why
would that happen?
MARK MANDEL: I have no idea.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I would like-- what
if you just did a live
coding for your talk at Next?
Because you do the live
streaming for coding, right?
MARK MANDEL: I do.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And do you
think they would approve it
if you did that as a session?
MARK MANDEL: I don't know
how interesting it is.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
hopefully people-- well, I
don't know.
I think it would
be kind of cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So actually, if you are
interested, usually about once
a week, I livestream on Twitch.
That's something I do usually,
if I'm not traveling anyway.
So you can follow me on
twitch.tv/MarkMandel,
or you can just have a look
for me on YouTube as well.
And I'll do livestreaming of
development of [INAUDIBLE]..
I do that fairly regularly.
So if you're like, I
wonder how Mark thinks,
and how much does he
actually talk to himself,
and how often does
his dog bug him,
then you have an
avenue for finding out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Minus the dog part,
that might make for a
really cool Next session.
I mean, even the
dog would be fine,
but I'm sure there would be
rules against bringing a dog.
MARK MANDEL: If [? Manny ?]
Chan can bring on her-- hamster,
I think it was--
into her I/O talk,
then I think I can
bring my dog on stage.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You
can bring the dog.
You can bring the audience
into the whole thing.
It could be like an actual
live coding session.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
It's just me sitting
there being like,
so, why isn't this working?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, 45 minutes
of me just sitting there cursing
at my computer, it turns out,
does not make for
entertaining television.
Or maybe it does.
MARK MANDEL: Anyway,
I'll tell you what.
If people are interested in
me doing that live on stage,
let me know.
I'd be happy to do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
It would be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, Mark, thank
you for joining me
on the episode of the
podcast this week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Always
good to chat with you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: And thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you next week.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]